hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm calmed down quite a bit
so welcome back to digression phobia
degress your phobia welcome ah it's such
a nice nice don't know how the hell
anyone was supposed to know that the key
was up above that door but hey swag
shows a dead body wow there's a dead
body in the torture chamber no calm I'm
calm
alright I read from the notes hang on
let me read you these notes because back
when before I was reading I realized
that I had all these right here but the
other ones I don't know if they mean
anything but you'll need two objects a
body from a dead human or dead human
body or a human corpse since is not
something you trip over at the street
you might need a special license poison
gland from the flower and then you you
have to drill a hole in the side of the
body's head then stuff the gland from
the floss immortalis inside the body
skull the juices from the gland will
then begin to flow inside the body and
then it mutates into a monster man oh
[Music]
yeah I feel sleepy oh stuffing things
into dead bodies is such hard work I'd
best go to sleep oh oh man it's just
such an adventure being a Jew porcinis
Oh funny thing you may have noticed my
open my inventory I was in the basement
again and I found a bottle of oil I
didn't even know how I scoured every
inch and I found a bottle of oil which
is like only weird because I don't even
have a lantern so I
anyway what the hell I am the monster
what what the hell so awesome this is
amazing
oh man oh I'm gonna gamma number I got
tunnel vision on you I think I'm moose
man if I'm not mistaken
Oh Oh what doc I can't go that way
apparently up wait um ah ah
huh I'm like totally focused must attack
door I'm gonna get this door haha I beat
you game
ha ha ha ha ha
you can't be me I'm too smart for you
alright fine I'll get ya ah it's so cool
of course I'm gonna play my free now now
I know give me the closet oh no clues it
blew that keep it closed I don't have a
lantern oh man
that is like the greatest thing ever oh
man that was awesome
oh man that makes me almost completely
forget about the whole key ordeal
[Music]
so cool oh man I got like I'm gonna have
a permanent mom I need a smile at me
it's quote Adam Savage hi buddy
I freaking made the monster that's
amazing
good thing I was so sleepy
[Music]
is there anything of value in this just
it's a broom closet it's quite literally
a closet of brooms and there's nothing
else that was awesome
honestly that was awesome that was
awesome that was awesome
like beyond awesome that was amazing now
well I mean I was seeing why
come on was so good before but now I see
cuz it innervates it's an innovator
what's all this then huh hello
just don't start doing the slender boom
bangs we'll get along just fine
I don't want to go down there tunnel
exit oh oh oh can't see jack
I can see Jill's Oh thing no that's
stupid
oh is this a friggin May zone Oh
[Music]
Oh
hammers scrapers I forget what the
official name for those things are these
are used to smooth wood their mechanical
devices that are meant to shoot down
everyone
you don't care what is this let's all
learn science with markiplier no where
am i go what am i do maybe I can build
something something with the wood but I
need a tool well I was just talking
about tool I got it no I got it - no my
god - oh no no no no thank you I don't
want any ways this is way back
yes no this is where I just was where
this is whether I just was where I want
to be the monster again this might be
the way yeah this is the way back
oh man I do not like how Maisie this is
ooh what up ha ha boy where did I just
go wounds and I saw meets aw that's not
I saw that I can use for wood I'm
guessing oh wow
Simon's getting all the fun what is it
what is it what is Mark doing huh marked
it all the hard work all you had to do
is find a key Simon and you're just too
stupid to find it yeah I could have
found the key sooner if I was playing
mark but just Simon whenever I play him
my hack here just drops like 20 points
it's locked
how about a meat show no I really don't
think they're gonna give me any a
lantern because if they haven't already
it's like oh god that's Turkey because
if they haven't gotten it already then
I'm assuming that it's not gonna happen
I found a saw I don't know if that's
actually gonna help me at all
why did be so dark let's see what was
alright I'm just plotting things out
again down here there was the wood
maybe I can build some why do I keep
hearing that how about this for a tool
can I get this it should have been it
should have been obvious what am I gonna
build
[Music]
ah I'm not ready for that
oh no come back here up guy was not
ready for that he's just like wanna be
here who says you know that's how I keep
hearing what I think is that you're
Steen monster and I don't know what okay
I think I'm gonna have to grab the other
tools from the area cuz that thing is
still nearby it's gone now I think yeah
it's gone it doesn't like me saw in the
wood okay so I know there was another
another there were more tools over in a
room over here we know what wait no I'm
on the wrong way Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry
Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry
I'm sorry people get me in here yes I
was just talking about these yeah uh-huh
it's funny actually that I mentioned
that I need them hammer
before I'll be able to see that
that doesn't sound good
where'd my hammer go where to go where
to go ah that's over here thank you
song song song hunk no oh come on
Wow
there we go more sign up hmm can't give
me I'm awesome for you what am I just
gonna play this little game here
constant back and forth of doing nothing
I need me to see any change happened oh
maybe I gotta do something about this
monster before I'm able to
build-it
there are more tools over here anyway
nope
screwdriver nope
ahem are I don't know where that guy
went though huh no okay rabbie this les
saw here good night yeah yeah yeah no no
fu was that you need a hammer to finish
this I have a hammer I had a hammer I
have a hammer it's right there aha don't
don't don't
donk jerk all right then I'll take a
ladder excuse me while I what did I see
I did not see an unsettling event I just
saw a monster coming my way if you could
call that unsettling
Oh oh yeah
Oh No
hello hello I do not know what is it far
I'm actually quite confused because I
all right I I don't even know why do I
need a letter I don't even remember
seeing oh the tunnel exit' I've bet I
bet my bottom dollar that it's for that
actually I am all out of time so
unfortunately it is gonna have to wait
until next time I'm actually making
progress yeah yeah yeah yeah anyway so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotations for more Let's Plays
that I've done and check out my reaction
compilations and as always I will see
you in the next video bye